-Welcome back, everybody!
I am hanging out
with Tom Hiddleston!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, there you go!
It is time right now
for "The Mimic Challenge."
Here we go.
-♪ Mimic challenge ♪
♪ Mimic, mimic challenge, yeah ♪
-Now here's how it works.
We're gonna take turns at making
noises with different objects,
and the other person has
to immediately match that sound
as precisely as they can.
-It's insane and foolish,
and I love it.
[ Laughter ]
-Since you're my guest,
you'll make the first noise,
and I will mimic.
-Okay.
Make this sound.
[ Bell ringing ]
[ Light laughter ]
-Didl-idl-idl-idl-idl-idl-idl-
idl-idl-idl-idl-idl-idl-idl!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-See what I'm saying?
-Yes!
Yes.
Amazing.
-Now it is your turn to mimic.
Tom, make this sound.
[ Laughter ]
[ Noodles cracking ]
-Okay.
[ Imitating cracking ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
♪♪
-That's actually really good.
All right.
All right, it's my turn.
Tom, you're up.
-Oh, sh-- uh, Jimmy...
[ Laughter ]
...make this sound.
[ Paper crinkling ]
-[ Whooshing ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-That was great.
That was great.
-I'm not good
at all of these sounds.
Yeah, all right.
But, Tom, I'm pretty good...
at this sound.
See if you can make this sound.
[ Laughter ]
Do I have to do this on camera,
or how does this work?
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Well, that way
is probably better?
All right, ready?
[ Laughter ]
Is that way better,
or, no, is that worse?
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what way is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
That way.
-Regular!
[ Laughter ]
-"Regular."
All right, let me start.
All right.
[ Rapid rattling ]
-Okay, okay.
[ Muffled grunting ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Ding! ]
Amazing.
-Well, there -- there --
there's the meme of the summer.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
All right, Tom.
Make this sound.
[ Honking ]
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know this is supposed
to make that sound, Tom.
[ Laughter ]
Ready?
[ Honking ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Heaving ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-Jimmy, make this sound.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Duck call sounds ]
[ Laughter ]
-Pwwwpppt!
Pwwwpppt!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
Pwwwpppt!
-Pretty good.
-All right, Tom,
let's do one more.
Tom, can you make this sound?
[ High-pitched air horn blares ]
[ Audience groans ]
-[ Squealing ]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
[ High-pitched air horn blares ]
[ Both squealing ]
-[ Squealing ]
-My thanks
to Tom Hiddleston right there!
Talented man!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Loki" is available on Disney+!